and on this first day of class some
parents are just learning that planned
after-school activities for their child
aren't happening we're talking about the
safe key program jeremy j ford joins us
live in the newsroom after speaking to
parents about this jeremy
yeah that's right parents in need of
afternoon care for their child can
utilize the safety program as it's
offered at different schools across the
valley well i spoke to one parent who
enrolled her child in the program but
came to find out just three days before
school started it was canceled
like scrambling around recruiting
family members seeing when they're off
trying to see if they can take them if
they can pick them up
desiree iverson has a child at dondera
elementary school in the southwest
valley she signed up for the safe key
after school care program but just days
before school was to start it was
dropped i did contact the admin and she
said that it was because
well the cafeteria building is a
standalone building and they're saying
that safekee didn't want to walk all the
way to open the gate every time a parent
came in and you know to pick up their
kid or drop their kid off yet there was
a fully functioning program last year
which she says is still needed because
without it now it's like you know
sacrificing the child's education
because a lot of parents have to work so
they're not able to bring their kids to
school and it's you know it's a whole
scramble of trying to figure it out
well iverson says she was reimbursed for
the payment she made to the safe key
program and is still trying to find
child care solutions and i spoke with
stacy welling with clark county who says
that parks and recreation run the
program at dondero she tells me they
want to keep the program at the school
and are actually trying to find a
solution to fix it from the newsroom
jeremy j ford live local now